this video was made possible by
curiosity stream sign up for the
curiosity stream nebula bundle deal at
curiositystream.comwendover to watch an
exclusive companion video diving deeper
into this video's subject
the first thing to know about the art
market is that it's tiny despite its
prominence in cinema literature and the
news the majority of the market is
composed of a small number of dealers
and auctioneers catering to an exclusive
list of ultra-rich clientele each year
on average 61.9 billion dollars of art
is sold
61.9 billion dollars is a big number but
not in context 61.9 billion dollars is
what walmart for example sells in just
41 days the global market of tomatoes
generates 190 billion dollars in annual
sales three times as much as art there
are single companies with greater annual
sales that you probably haven't even
heard of axa the centen corporation exor
the mckesson corporation the entire art
market is smaller than each of these
the second thing to know about the art
market is that it's extraordinarily
consolidated over the past decade 82
percent of sales by value were made in
the us uk or greater china that's to say
the global art market is a phenomenon
largely restricted to new york london
and hong kong but the consolidation
doesn't end there 43 of art dealers
nearly half had fewer than 20 unique
buyers in 2020 their sale and buyer
numbers can be as limited as those of
realtors which starts to make sense when
comparing the sale prices of the two
markets
unsurprisingly this means that power in
the industry is extraordinarily
concentrated too one study found that 30
of solo exhibitions at museums in the
u.s considered the hallmark of success
featured artists represented by one of
just five galleries once you move into
the upper echelons of the industry
however the concentration intensifies
during the studied period 11 out of 12
solo exhibitions at the guggenheim
considered one of the world's preeminent
art museums presented artists
represented by one of the same five
galleries
so to summarize the key features of this
market are that it is small and
concentrated without knowing anything
more an economist could tell you that
this is theoretically a market ripe for
exploitation and corruption
but that's just theory
to understand where the malpractice
occurs one must first understand the
practice how art sales work
nearly three decades ago in 1994 artist
roy lichtenstein put on one of the last
solo shows of his career for this he
created a series of nude portraits a
novel subject for lichtenstein presented
in his archetypical style now in order
to translate his work into income
liechtenstein partnered with the leo
castelli gallery this was no surprise as
castelli and his gallery had been long
time partners of the pop art icon three
decades prior castelli had presented
lichtenstein's first ever one man show
the two had formed a professional
relationship over the years prior while
lichtenstein worked as an assistant art
professor at rutgers university and
castelli believed his work could be a
commercial success
he was of course correct as every single
piece was sold prior to the show's
opening this skyrocketed lichtenstein's
career overnight he was transformed from
essentially a hobbyist into an
internationally known commercially
successful professional artist
so for all intents and purposes castelli
made liechtenstein
therefore liechtenstein stuck with
castelli throughout his career which
brought him to that 1994 exhibition
entitled nude's nine color relief prints
as is common in the high-end art world
it's difficult to precisely trace the
ownership history of given works but we
know that one of the pieces nude with
joy's painting was sold by the castelli
gallery to a private collector in new
york then sold by the james goodman
gallery to a private collector in
detroit before it was purchased by an
unknown new owner that new owner then
decided in 2020 to sell the painting
therefore they contacted christie's
now christie's and its primary
competitor sotheby's are the big movers
and shakers in the art market
they're auction houses and facilitate
the sale of much of the world's most
expensive art of the 10 highest price
sales in 2020 eight occurred at either
christie's or sotheby's
their process starts with an appraisal
each auction house employs in-house
experts who determine what they believe
a piece will sell for and present a
range a lower number and a higher number
then assuming they want to move forward
the auction house and seller will
mutually agree to a reserve price a
number equal to or less than the lower
range of the estimate under which they
will not sell the piece even if an offer
is submitted typically with higher end
sales however the auction house will
persuade the seller to use their
services by guaranteeing the sale
agreeing to purchase the artwork
themselves for the lower end of the
estimate even if no bids are submitted
on the other end of the spectrum the
auction house takes a two percent fee if
a piece of artwork is sold above the
upper estimate to incentivize
performance although this is often
waived in contract negotiations with the
seller the seller also pays a percentage
fee supposedly as much as 10 for lower
priced works and as low as 2 for higher
priced works although official numbers
are not published and are highly subject
to negotiation as auction houses are
eager to bring in sellers the bulk of
the auction house's money is made from
the buyer they pay on top of the final
sale price a percentage fee at most
christie's auction houses it's 25 on
sales up to 600 000 20 for sales up to
six million then fourteen and a half
percent on sales above that number this
is all to say when christie's or
sotheby's gets their hands on the kind
of artwork that lists for tens of
millions of dollars they are highly
highly financially motivated to make the
sale
roy lichtenstein's nude with joyous
painting falls into this category a
deceased highly commercially successful
artist a break from style piece created
towards the end of its artist's career
there was a lot going for this painting
and christie's knew it
therefore they scheduled its auction to
take place at one of the top events of
the year
under the constraints of the covet 19
pandemic the auction house organized a
new format for one of 2020's biggest
auctions while each of their auctions
typically occur under the banner of one
of their locations their hong kong paris
london and new york auction houses
teamed up to run a simultaneous global
live streamed auction
now of the 79 lots put up for auction
the absolute least expensive was a piece
by matthew wong a praise between 60 and
80 thousand dollars
most were well into the millions and
this was by design
christie's sotheby's and other auction
houses will aggregate their highest
priced works together into a few yearly
auctions so that they can turn them into
can't miss events for the art world
their job is essentially the marketing
they're trying to build anticipation and
excitement for the sale of a given piece
so they'll spend the months prior
working their catalog of buyers talking
to the press and exhibiting works all
around the world
then after almost all of their work is
completed the night of the auction
arrives
in this case the event started with hong
kong their auctioneer live streamed to
the world sold nine relatively lower
priced works before passing the torch to
paris from where 15 higher priced lots
were auctioned then it moved on to
london where hammer prices crept further
and further into the millions and
finally it was new york's turn saving
the best for last all of the true
headliners were auctioned from new york
this included picassos basquiats calders
o'keefe's war halls and of course the
liechtenstein
bidding opened on nude with joyous
painting at 20 million dollars that was
quickly pushed up to 22 26 28 then 29
million dollars two anonymous bidders
from new york aided by phone laden
representatives at the auction house
pushed the price up by half million
increments to 36 until a buyer from hong
kong swooped in and bid 37 million one
of the new york bidders responded with
38 million dollars then the other new
york bidder came back with 38.2
it went to 38.5 39
5 40 before the hong kong buyer bid 40.5
million dollars which meant no response
and the auctioneer's hammer came down on
what would become the third highest
priced art sale of the year with fees
the buyer ended up paying 46 million 242
thousand five hundred dollars meaning
christie's netted at least five million
seven hundred and forty two thousand
five hundred dollars from the 10 minute
and 14 seconds long auction across the
evening though some
421 million dollars of art was sold
that means this one four hour event and
its 79 lots accounted for almost a full
percent of the entire world's art sales
in 2020 by value and that christie's as
a company earned upwards of 60 million
dollars
so
where's the problem
so far most of this process probably
seems above board it's just a collection
of wealthy people buying and selling
expensive art through a few exclusive
auction houses well it's not so much the
process itself but what it enables
most of the issues arise out of a simple
truth art does not have intrinsic value
say you stopped by a thrift store saw
this painting on the wall and it had no
label no price tag no information at all
beyond the peace itself how much would
you pay for it some would only spare 20
or 30 dollars while others impressed
with its intricacy and age might pay a
couple hundred dollars for it
this is roughly what happened in 1958
when it was presented to a small auction
in london as a poorly maintained copy of
a lost work by leonardo da vinci and
sold for 45 pounds to minnie and warren
koontz the couple carried the painting
with them to southampton then boarded
the ship bound for houston to return
from their european vacation in 1987 the
artwork was inherited by kunsa's nephew
basil clovis hendry who hung it in his
baton rouge louisiana home until his
death in 2004.
his daughter susan hendry turrell
brought the work and much of the rest of
her father's estate to the new orleans
auction gallery where it was listed with
a sale estimate of twelve to eighteen
hundred dollars
it was bought for an unknown amount less
than ten thousand dollars by a pair of
art dealers alexander parrish and robert
simon who had a long shot hunch that it
could be worth far more than that
they therefore hired a paintings
conservator from nyu to restore the work
and as part of her process she took
infrared photographs of the piece to be
able to see through the layers of paint
this unearthed the lowest layer which
included the very first strokes the ones
the artist took to outline the general
composition of the painting these first
strokes largely matched up with the
final product except for here the thumb
they outlined the thumb in a straight
position rather than the curved shape
seen in all known copies of the lost
davinci painting it seemed that the
artist changed their mind which would
make no sense when copying a painting
these few hidden strokes served as a
crucial initial piece of evidence that
this might be the original salvator
mundi painted by leonardo da vinci
himself
therefore perish and simon spent the
better part of the next five years
traveling around showing the piece to
experts and curators garnering support
for their theory in 2011 they attained
definitive validation london's national
gallery exhibited the salvatore mundi
and the name on the label read leonardo
da vinci the value instantly
and simon sold the piece to another
dealer for 80 million dollars who
immediately sold it to a russian
collector for 127 million dollars who
then brought the piece to auction
only the 24th known painting widely
attributed to da vinci and one of only
two not held by a museum this was sure
to fetch an eye-popping price
after a world tour of exhibitions
leonardo's salvator mundi was sold by
christie's new york for 450 million
three hundred and twelve thousand five
hundred dollars to saudi crown prince
mohammed bin salman an all-time record
price for the sale of a piece of art
prior to the recognition by top museums
that this piece was in fact a da vinci
the value was in the low thousands
after it was in the hundreds of millions
that's to say
art has no intrinsic value the value for
what christie's sotheby's or other top
auction houses sell is all in who
painted it who owned it and who wants it
an uninformed person can look at a car
or a plate of food or a house and guess
with some accuracy what it's worth but
that's not the case with art nearly all
of the value is invisible because the
value is simply what other people are
willing to pay
now
here's the question would you genuinely
believe that if you had bought that
dilapidated portrait of jesus at the
estate auction in new orleans you could
have successfully convinced the national
gallery in london that it was a true da
vinci
do you believe that if back in 1960 rory
lichtenstein had met you instead of
castelli you could have successfully
convinced enough people of the artist's
future prospects to sell at his first
show prior to opening any answer but no
is arrogant
value in the art world is defined by an
incredibly small number of gatekeepers
the curators gallery owners and
auctioneers
so to summarize the art world is an
incredibly small incredibly consolidated
market where prices are almost entirely
subjective
these three factors combined mean that
properly executed sellers can decide
what prices are between 2005 and 2013
one fourth of all andy warhol works put
up for auction were bought by a single
man jose mugrabbi now mugrabbi owns over
800 warhol artworks in total
representing close to a billion dollars
in value at least on paper therefore
mugrabi is highly highly invested in
making sure that the warhol market stays
hot
now there is of course a reason why in
more traditional markets monopolies and
oligopolies are disallowed when power is
too concentrated a single player can
influence the entire market to their own
benefits
that's exactly what mugrabbi does
whenever a warhol is up for sale at
auction he'll be there
often mugabe will be one of the first to
bid and will work to push up prices with
his early offers mugrabbi is more than
willing to strategically overpay for a
warhol work because he knows that it'll
be worth it that's because auctions act
as the only publicly available index of
art prices when one private individual
sells artworks to another private
individual the price is not public
knowledge when one private individual
sells artwork at auction the price is
public knowledge
so that means that mugrabbi is willing
to go to an auction and bid copiously
regardless of the actual market value
either he'll have pushed up the price
for another bidder which is good for him
or he'll have overpaid for the art which
is still good for him that's because
either way the fact that a warhol works
sold for a good price and the world
knows it pushes up the hypothetical
value of the rest of his warhol pieces
which he can then sell for more in
private what's more this manner of
market manipulation is entirely legal
collectors will choose a niche and then
dominate it
plus given the small size of the
high-end art market mugrabi almost
certainly knows all the other top war
hall collectors and collectively they
realize that if one of them sells a
piece publicly for a bad price it'll
hurt all of their portfolio values so an
informal social cabal arises that
further influences the market and
artificially inflates values however
this is only the tip of the iceberg the
same market conditions that enable
mugrabbi's influence mean that collusion
and corruption are confoundingly easy
there isn't one blockbuster scam at the
center of the art market
rather it's a market composed of scams
for example counter-intuitively wealthy
individuals can turn a profit by
donating art it's rather simple in the
u.s when one donates artwork to a
non-profit museum they get a tax
write-off that's to say if someone
donates a painting worth 10 million
dollars they don't have to pay taxes on
10 million dollars of income which in
theory would save them about 4 million
dollars of course given the difficulties
in determining arts worth the irs
requires expensive artwork to be
professionally appraised prior to a
write-off considering all the
aforementioned market conditions though
it's not tough to manipulate an
appraisal to go one's way
of the hundreds of thousands of artworks
donated each year the irs audits only a
couple hundred but even those few paint
a stark picture in 2018 and 2019 about a
third of audited artwork was found to be
overvalued in its appraisal by an
average of 38
in fact overall only 42 percent of
artwork was found to have been appraised
correctly in part thanks to the
competing pressure for some to
undervalue their work when it's received
through inheritance in order to reduce
the estate taxes paid upon transfer of
ownership
so a rich person could buy a piece of
art for four million dollars let it
appreciate over a few years shop around
for a favorable appraisal overstate its
value rely on the fact that the irs only
audits a tiny percentage of prices
donate the art for 10 million dollars
and they'll have already broken even it
doesn't take much for the percentage a
wealthy person will save in taxes to
eclipse their original purchase price as
a cherry on top of course the presence
of an artist's work in a museum is known
to inflate the value of their other art
so if a wealthy person owns a collection
of a given artist's work as is common
donations earn them further money
through the effect it has on the rest of
their collection in aggregate the
situation is this it was created by rich
people for rich people so it suits their
needs whether it's tax avoidance money
laundering or simple price fixing the
art market enables all despite this it's
almost entirely unregulated there are no
official records of who owns what or how
much they paid so it's nearly impossible
to prove any malpractice in the market
it's a largely lawless market except for
the simple practical rule that you must
be able to spend millions to enter it
so
who loses out well for one artists
rich people use artwork like trading
cards coveting a select view for
arbitrary reasons which excludes those
who are unable to persuade the
gatekeepers of their value those who
don't fit the gallery's vision of a
marketable artist
art is no longer an exercise of skill
it's one of branding warhols are like
supreme but for the wealthiest percent
of a percent
who also loses out is us everyone who is
unable to access this exclusive market
by sinking millions of dollars into a
single volatile investment we lose out
because we can't conduct the same
financial wizardry as those who walk
through sotheby's doors
we can access the stock market where tax
avoidance money laundering and price
fixing are heavily regulated and
monitored but not this market where
these ruses go largely unnoticed the
reality is that any market can be
exploited which is why markets are
regulated the difference here is that
art is a unique market where individual
players have both the influence to
manipulate the market and the influence
to keep the market manipulatable
everything you've heard so far is about
the largely legal malpractice the art
market enables but it also makes illegal
actions like money laundering and
forgery strikingly easy therefore as
usual i made an exclusive nebula
companion video diving deeper into that
subject for those who found this video
particularly interesting i was able to
do that because nebula unlike youtube
has no algorithm to punish me for
publishing a video that only the most
engaged viewers are going to be
interested in nebula was founded and is
owned by creators so it's meant to be
the best home to our content with no ads
and a financial model that enables
exclusive companion videos and big
budget nebula originals we've also made
sure that nebula is the absolute best
deal in the streaming world by
partnering with curiositystream now when
you sign up for any subscription at
curiositystream.comwendover
you get access to nebula 2. that means
for the cost of a fancy cheeseburger
less than 15 a year you can watch all of
nebula and all of curiosity's stream
including havel their first ever
original feature film telling the true
story of a famed british actor who
dropped everything to join the fight
against isis in syria considering you
get both nebula and curiosity stream for
a year for what you pay for a month of
other streaming services you can tell
why i call it the best deal in streaming
and even while getting that amazing deal
you'll be supporting wendover and all
the other independent nebula creators so
click the button on screen or head to
curiositystream.com
to sign up for the bundle deal today